how do you fix Twitter how did you fix
social media for your own
like you're an optimist you're a
positive person there's a bit of a
cynicism that you have currently about
this particular Little slice of humanity
I tend to think I'm not that cynical
about it
I actually refused
yes I was just
really expressing some personal path
personal stuff it was just some personal
pathos but like
like just to vent a little bit just I
don't have I don't have cancer I've I
love my family I have a good life I'm
that that is if that is my biggest one
of my biggest problems that's a good
life yeah I I you know that was a brief
although I do think there are a lot of
issues with Twitter just in terms of
like the public mental health but
due to my proximity to the current
dramas
I honestly feel that I should not have
opinions about this because
I think
if Elon ends up
getting Twitter
that is a being the Arbiter of Truth or
public discussion that is a
responsibility
I do not I I
am not qualified to be responsible for
that and I do not want to
say something that might like dismantle
democracy and so I just like actually I
actually think I should not have
opinions about this because I truly am
not I don't want to have the wrong
opinion about this and I think I'm too
close to the actual situation yeah uh
wherein I I should not have I I have
thoughts in my brain but I think
um I'm scared by my proximity to this
situation is this isn't that crazy that
a few words that you could say
could change world affairs and hurt
people I mean that's the nature of
celebrity at a certain point
um that you have to be you have to a
little bit a little bit not so much that
it destroys you or puts too much
constraints but you have to a little bit
think about the impact of your words I
mean we as humans you talk to somebody
at a bar you have to think about the
impact of your words like you could say
positive things you can think of
negative things you can affect the
direction of one life but on social
media your words can affect the
direction of
many lives that's crazy it's a crazy
world to live in it's uh worthwhile to
consider that responsibility take it
seriously sometimes just like you did
uh choose kind of
silence
choose sort of respectful
like I do have a lot of thoughts on the
matter I'm just
um yeah I just I don't if my thoughts
are wrong this is this is what one
situation where the stakes are high you
you mentioned a while back that you were
in a cult that centered around
bureaucracy so you can't really do
anything because it involves a lot of
paperwork and I really love a cult
that's just like kafka-esque you know
just like I mean it was like a joke but
I know but I love this idea the holy
rain Empire yeah it was just like a
kafka-esque
um Pro bureaucracy but I feel like
that's what human civilization is is
that because when you said that I was
like oh that is kind of what humanity is
is this bureaucracy I do yeah I have
this
Theory I really think that um
we really
bureaucracy is is starting to kill us
and I think
like
we need to reorient laws and stuff like
I think we just need Sunset classes on
everything like I think the rate of
change in culture is happening so fast
in the rate of change in technology and
everything is happening so fast it's
like you know when you see these
hearings about like like
social media and Cambridge analytica and
everyone talking it's like even from
that point so much technological change
has happened from like those hearings
and it's just like we're trying to make
all these laws now about Ai and stuff I
feel like we should be updating things
like every five years and like one of
the big issues in our society right now
is we're just getting bogged down by
laws and it's um making it very hard to
change things and develop things like in
Austin like I don't want to speak on
this
um
too much but like one of my friends is
working on a housing bill in Austin to
try to like prevent like a San Francisco
situation from happening here because
obviously we're getting a little mini
San Francisco here like housing prices
are skyrocketing is causing massive
gentrification
um this is gonna be this is really bad
for
um anyone who's not super rich like like
there's so much bureaucracy part of the
reason this is happening is because you
need all these permits to build it takes
like years to get permits to like build
anything it's so hard to build and so
there's very limited housing and there's
a massive influx of people and it's just
like you know this is a microcosm of
like problems that are happening all
over the world where it's just like
we're dealing with laws that are like 10
20 30 40 100 200 years old and they are
no longer relevant and it's just slowing
everything down and causing massive
social pain
yeah it was it's like it's also makes me
sad when I see politicians talk about
technology and when they don't really
get it and but most importantly they
lack curiosity and like that like
inspired excitement yeah like how stuff
works and all that's the digits like
they see they have the very cynical view
of Technology it's like tech companies
are just trying to evil in the world
from their perspective and they have no
curiosity about like how recommender
systems work or how how AI systems work
natural language processing how robotics
Works how computer Vision Works you know
uh they always think the the most
cynical possible interpretation of what
technology will be used and we should
definitely be concerned about that but
if you're constantly worried about that
and you're regulating based on that
you're just going to slow down all the
Innovation I do think a huge priority
right now is undoing
um the bad
energy
um surrounding the emergence of Silicon
Valley like I think that like a lot of
things were very irresponsible during
that time and um you know like even just
this current whole thing with Twitter
and everything it's like like there's
been a lot of negative outcomes from
uh the sort of technocracy Boom but uh
one of the things that's happening is
that like it's alienating people from
wanting to care about technology and I
actually think technology is
probably some of the better probably
the best
I think we can fix a lot of our problems
more easily with technology than with
um you know fighting the powers that be
as a you know not to go back to the Star
Wars quote or the [ __ ] myself quote